I spent
two and a half years designing a coat
hanger
and I just can't stop thinking about it
like I get so into it because I think
it's so much fun
take me to this
two-year journey of the code hanging out
of the code hanger what how did it begin
how did it begin it began with a corner
in my home where I couldn't fit a coat
rack the thing is I shouldn't have
brought this up because I'm gonna
release it as a product probably in a
year on an actual product okay well it
is a mystery it's a mystery yeah it
solves a fundamental problem in in The
Human Condition and I am so excited
about it and I cannot I don't yeah but
this is I get so
pumped about it because I see it's just
this issue or like this problem that I
want to solve and I kind of can't put it
to rest until I have it's I mean
speaking of cone hangers
um doorknobs have always been
interesting to me
it's cool how there's things that
everybody uses that somebody designed
Lex yeah oh my God so okay so this is I
so I have two like big so basically I
started on YouTube and I'm uh been doing
that for like the last seven or eight
years and I've kind of been thinking of
like okay what's next for me because I
want to keep on trying out new things
and I'm I'm kind of
going into two different Avenues one is
the product business that I started code
hinders TBD
um and then I am working on a pilot
episode of a show where each episode is
about an everyday object and why they
look the way that they do so we've
written a pilot episode about forks and
it's all about like why do they look the
way that they do why did this became the
like eating Implement of the West why
are we ruled by an iron Fork how did
that happen in every everyday object
that you have and that you just take for
granted somebody just made it up yeah
we're all sheep well I'll keep using it
yeah even if it's not optimal I mean
presumably most objects are optimal you
hope or at least a local options yeah
and that's what I think is so like the
world around us and this is why I love
building things is because it just opens
up this idea that the world around us is
so malleable and you can make objects
work for you better like I spent I I
made this fruit bowl I had a fruit bowl
and I was always in annoyed that I had
either too little or too much fruit for
it so I made a fruit bowl where I can
change the diameter of it it has a
mechanism so you can like make it bigger
or smaller and that's just like the
thing of being like
bowls why are they the way that they are
I could make them different and I think
like I want to make an episode about
doorknobs I think it's so interesting
why are they the way they are why are
they placed the way where they are I
think that's going to be a rabbit hole
from which you will never return I would
happily live in that rabbit hole forever
like if I could if I can like dig out a
little niche for myself there because I
think it's like
you know they go so deep they're also on
different sides of doors you never like
the push-pull situation on doors in
general like that's one of the main
problems of humanity
figuring out which is embarrassing okay
I mean there's eight billion peoples on
people on Earth every single second
there is millions of people being
embarrassed by the confusion
some guy first time in college he's
trying to be impressive to everybody to
pushes on and he plays it off like it's
cool oh I knew that nope over and
over and it affects our behaviors that
was why I think it's so interesting with
forks is that Forks actually affect our
eating behaviors and they can get you to
eat faster or slower take bigger bites
or smaller bites and they're all these
ways or like the social I mean the
reason that
um Chopsticks work is because they do
the food shopping in kitchen
rather than on the plate and also you
have a bowl that you bring to your mouth
with whereas a plate you keep on the
like they're just all these ways in
these objects affect our Behavior
opening and closing doors and I think
it's such an interesting take on culture
through and like human behavior through
these objects that we use every day and
we never question them really yeah and
then there's institutions that are
controlling our mind that don't want us
to know the truth why are sporks not
more popular have you asked yourself
that question yeah no it's all big
utensil is behind all of it